boy oh boy I can't wait to find out how
important nuts are in this episode
spongebob is a dictum ailment also this
is a thing that spongebob does every day
why would the male fish man be surprised
also also since when can spongebob
shrink himself and his clothing down to
a tiny version of himself he's hiding
inside the mailbox here it has enough
room for this to be a small apartment
it's funny I don't remember subscribing
to fancy live in digest that's funny I
don't remember the fire working
underwater but here we are this guy's so
rich he has a swimming pool in a
swimming pool and in the ocean so he's
rich and stupid so why doesn't Squidward
pants SpongeBob and Patrick wear pants I
prefer my Squidward with pants they are
entrepreneurs they sell thanks to people
what kind of things how should I know
thanks people 105 but Squidward is the
one reading the magazine articles about
the people so shouldn't he know exactly
what they saw Patrick we got to become
entrepreneurs but when is someone going
to become concern that the mail was
never taken out of the mailbox by the
mail fish man flag is up goddamnit
quick Patrick without thinking if you
could have anything in the world right
now what would it be doing the paper
chocolate chocolate chocolate ah sudden
unexpected Corona o'clock you guys want
to be good salesmen right oh oh come on
when did they have time to practice
responding to a question with perfect
synchronicity you two lady killers are
too smart to be without one of my
patented candy bar bag carrying bags we
3:20 SpongeBob and Patrick could afford
to buy all these bags from Death of a
Salesman here then why do they need to
sell the candy bars looks like they have
plenty of money you know everyone thinks
Patrick is stupid but he's the only one
smart enough to wear swim trunks in the
bottom of the goddamn ocean she is
surprisingly under-reacting for the show
on her doorstep a panicking sponge and a
near nude starfish time to call the
police don't you think did all the other
bags go they were all over the place
just a second ago did Patrick eat them
after ate them didn't they find out this
lunatic is obsessed with chocolate and
wants to buy it all so why isn't he
stopping to scoop them off the street
media a new approach a new tactic
we could it let's get naked no let's
save that for we're selling real estate
wait what sorry chocolate has sugar and
sugar turns to bubbling fat actually not
completely true your body converts the
sugar into energy and since it converts
so easily it's usually the first calorie
to be burned however if you're not
exercising or doing some sort of
activity back up jack so wait Patrick
sighs can't really do that because that
brings up so many more questions that
I'll have very little desire to know the
answers to yelling you just can't wait
for me to die can go dear god what is
this it's giving me flashbacks to
Eraserhead and anything that gives me
flashbacks to Eraserhead can drop
instantly they're selling chocolate
chocolate hate you man yet you will
double date before the end of this if we
keep exaggerating the truth we'll be
fancy living in no time modern-day
Commerce funny rumors at all but how the
hell did he create the glass breaking
sound when he fell there's no one left
in town to sell chocolate bars to no one
well that's a boy I don't watch the show
and I for sure didn't see them try to
deliver chocolate to a few fan favorites
but okay let's wrap up we need a new
friend - are you up spongebob not if you
keep letting those dollar bills float
away yeah how long have you two ladies
known each other
this show
okay what's your love cookie
make sure you click that Bell icon but
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video so click Oh what can I
do for you two nice young man do you
want a chocolate chocolates not for
eating it rubs the lotion on its skin or
else it gets the hose again I was born
with glass bones and paper skin you
called me mr. plants what is wrong with
you people
thank you for your patronage moisturize
me moisturize me